good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I've
seen up close how the celebrity
industrial complex can manufacture
heroic narratives around almost any
person or for that matter manufacturer
villainous ones whichever is more
fiscally useful and I'm disturbed by
corporations commodifying human souls to
sell movie tickets by the way I'm on my
way to get a haircut and I know the only
reason people are talking about Keanu
Reeves right now is because he has a new
movie out and various PR machinations
are incredibly good at getting us to
give that movie free advertising but
still I freaking love Keanu Reeves and
haircut now listen I don't think Keanu
Reeves is like a golden God or anything
if you want people to admire look to
teachers and librarians not actors or
for that matter novelists I don't think
he honor Reeves has like achieved
enlightenment or whatever I just think
that from what I know of him Keanu
Reeves has come closer to achieving
enlightenment than any other famous
person but let's start with his work
Keanu Reeves is a great actor some
people don't get his acting which is
fine some people don't get why
Shakespeare was a great playwright but
he still was speaking of which when
Keanu Reeves turned down 11 million
dollars to be in speed 2 and instead
played Hamlet in Winnipeg Manitoba the
Sunday Times critic called his
performance one of the top three
Hamlet's I have seen for a simple reason
he is Hamlet
look I don't labor under the delusion
that Keanu Reeves has never been in a
bad movie but I do believe he's never
been bad in a movie he's a great comic
actor Bill and Ted as a classic he's a
wonderful dramatic actress II for
instance his wrenching performance in my
own private Idaho and he's an action
icon there's an old line Hollywood
producers ask about actors sure he can
act but can he hold a gun Keanu Reeves
can hold a gun but what most fascinates
me about Keanu is his work off screen in
dealing with the press and in being a
famous person who is seemingly able to
maintain a sense of self which I can
report is a tricky business even for
those of us who aren't the faces of
billion dollar movie franchises Keanu is
the kind of person who might in an
interview say that he respects Buddhism
but has not quote taken refuge in the
Dharma or he might dismiss Hollywood
gossip by saying that it exists in
another universe that doesn't have much
to do with me or he might refer to the
endless minification of his life as
quote that internet deal Hank as you
pointed out in your video what makes
Keanu so brilliant at interviewing is
that he really listens he listens to
wisely the question that is being asked
and then he answers it carefully before
I knew any actors I thought that acting
was about pretending like I basically
thought it was a form of lying but
really I think acting is mostly about
listening right so because of all these
interviews and because he's been a
public figure for decades there's a lot
we know about Keanu Reeves we know that
he's dyslexic that he attended four
different high schools that he has
written a funny book about being sad
called ode to happiness we know that he
plays the bass and reads Proust and
co-founded a motorcycle company but
really we don't know much at all about
Keanu Reeves as he once noted on Mickey
Mouse they don't know who's inside the
suit
indeed we don't when I was younger I
wanted to be famous because I thought it
would be nice to have people like me but
when my work became publicly known I
never felt as if people liked me I felt
as if they liked Mickey Mouse I became
interested in Keanu Reeves because he
seemed to have found a way through that
complexity and what I've concluded after
reading interviews and stories about him
is that we don't know who's in his
Mickey Mouse suit but Keanu does and
that's all that matters and yeah it is
nice to be able to sit on a park bench
without having to worry about being
photographed
but with that problem which is very real
comes opportunities which are also very
real not just opportunities to lend your
voice to causes that matter but also
opportunities to make people's days
better by taking selfies with them or by
photobombing their wedding pictures now
of course it's easy to make people happy
when you're wearing a Mickey Mouse suit
but each of us has the opportunity every
day to be kind to others and to listen
carefully to them thanks for teaching me
that Keanu Hank I'll see you on Friday